[Musique]
vers les enfants
[Rires]
[Musique]
bravo nounours patron la musique chasse
le mauvais temps y apporte la bonne
humeur une douloureuse descente chez ses
amis ou les châles hop hop hop hop hop
hop hop en
europe à port
bou soir les petits
d'ivanhoe des chutes alors nous allons
faire un nouveau jeu non neutres et par
an
surprise
[Musique]
c'est un secret et c'est une surprise tu
verras cap 1 c'est une très grande
surprise et moi je l'aude
[Musique]
à présent on mettre au travail
ce n est qu on atteint
quand je l'entends je suis content
c'est la fête on va s'amuser
nous ne nous accompagner au monteur se
lève plus joli manège remonter sur les
chevaux de bois
on ira jouer aux anneaux
on regardera le zoo ton
on rencontrait des amis
tout ça nous aurons deux aussi nous nous
irons chercher de grogne aussi c'est que
nous concerne et je te défie nous garde
approchant sera fatigué
fera se reposent les
jeunes après la dînette
on habitait se coucher
[Applaudissements]
dis tu nous emmènerons vraiment un jour
sur le manège j'ai reçu et bien tout est
prêt on n'attend plus que la surprise
moi en orient qui pousse
ne serait plus une surprise
aliens que la voilà
qu'est ce que ça peut bien
[Musique]
bonne nuit petit cachottier
la juge est à l'honneur
à deux bouts
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vos nuits les enfants
alors nounours patron de mal nous aurons
une grande surprise
vous ne savez pas ce que ça par hasard
non
allons gros un patient en route route
fait pour
[Musique]